welcome to the program uh
just wore a t-shirt today and then
seconds before going on
thought that's not enough went to my car
found this jacket i've had forever in
the trunk
that's why i'm dressed like a man having
a horrible
mid-life crisis old jacket found in the
car
anyway that's what you get when you're
making a show in abandoned theater
during a pandemic
all right great show tonight mike
berbiglia very funny gentleman will be
on the program
speaking of funny gentlemen
[Laughter]
i never do transitions andy richter hi
did you hear that
that was nice i did it was i i thought
you were to talk about me
oh when you heard funny gentlemen yeah
yeah because i mean i'm
i mean i'm i'm here basically and also
you're the only one here i exist
yeah i like too that your midlife crisis
jacket is an old jacket
i know meaning you've already gone
through it yeah
that's just a sort of a hint at how old
i really am
is that you've come to terms yeah i
found my midlife crisis jacket in the
car
from like eight years ago yeah yeah it's
been driving around do you ever do that
do you ever keep
a jacket in your car in case
you're stuck somewhere and it got cold
suddenly you don't have a jacket
i used to do that all the time but now i
have a big dog so there's no room for
anything but
dog yeah yeah we could wear the dog
i keep talking to her about it but she's
just not
amenable